[Music]
let's go out to as Texans call it
Southern Canada let's go out to Oklahoma
and talk to Tyler what's up
Tyler hey how are you just dancing Like
It's
1999 what's up that's awesome well yeah
I wrote my question down can I just read
it of course awesome so um yeah so
there's a group of parents there's about
five families from our kids school and
we spend a lot of time with them we do a
lot of baseball games you know baseball
practices School event and uh we started
hanging out with everyone outside of
that on like weekend trips uh birthday
dinners random outings and the girls do
dinner outings and uh the guys we all
play in like a softball league
together and uh you know we thought we
were in the group and we did all these
events together and we we were close
with everyone but we found out that uh
the rest of the group celebrated
someone's birthday in the group uh
without us and that stung pretty good
and when we asked about their evening
the next day it went of the kids games
uh the group wasn't quite honest with us
which hurt and uh you know we found out
that night on social media what was
going on and uh we thought we were close
with all these families but the Omission
made us really question it and so my
question is how do we build meaningful
relationships with these families that
goes beyond just you know doing these
random things that turns into a real
friendship you know we see a lot of
potential in them and ever since this
event it uh really I don't know started
making us question
everything yeah that stinks me and it
feel like to be left out huh yeah it did
it hurt pretty good do you have a
guess um well we had a little bit of an
update I don't know if this is a guest
we started thinking about our you know
relationship with all of them and and
noticed that we there's a little bit of
a socioeconomic gap between us and them
and so I think we were embarrassed by
that and so we weren't inviting people
to go out you know one-on-one or like
double dates or anything like that for a
while and um since this event we just
just T like talked uh my wife and I
talked about just getting over ourselves
and inviting them to our house even
though it's real small compared to them
you know things like that and we started
to notice that's actually helped a
little bit and just um when we're around
everyone like leaning in and being extra
you know relational about you know
what's going on with their
life I think that what you just said is
really really
important and I think that type of
reflection is hard these days but I'm
proud of y'all for doing that so if I
hear you right they do pretty well y'all
aren't at the same level as they
are and yall have some
self-consciousness about
it yeah there's that and we were burned
by some friends in the past and I think
there's a little bit of that too so want
how are you how are you burned in the
past um we had some real close friends
that um just started getting really
weird with the mans in the friend group
and then started just acting like not
great to one another a little bit of
backstabbing and so we we removed
ourselves from that friend group uh
through some time and and space and we
actually mov cities too so how did you
get burned by
it um I think we were hurt with uh so
one of them um rented one of our houses
which was probably not the smartest
decision correct and um they they came
in you know we if we thought it would be
like wonderful and you know maintain the
friendship and then they slid a one day
at dinner slid A List of Demands on
updates to the house that they expected
us to make and then just started you
know demanding different things as
tenants which yeah hindsight is 2020 we
probably wouldn't do that again
um yeah you made a friend you allowed a
friendship to turn into a business
transaction yeah yeah that's tough um
yeah I often push back sometimes I get a
lot of flak for it and that's fine I
think it's not wise to be best buddies
with the person who pay write your
paycheck oh yeah I think we learned that
we won't do that again right here's what
I'm hearing a pattern of you
guys weigh into
something and then you just get
hurt hurts our feelings hurts our
feelings hurts our
feelings and it sounds like you guys
made probably not the wisest move by
allowing some friends to move into a
house that needed some work done on it
and maybe your friends were a little
over the top with their requests
but my guess is once they made those
requests you were like yeah that's for
sure my that that friend of ours like of
course they would do that to anybody we
knew that like now that we see it we're
like oh yeah that's how they would do
that to any landlord it wasn't just
personal and they probably were they
probably were
like dude like
the they got to do these of course they
got to do these things you see what I'm
saying and then you have new friends
that you're like well we're kind of
embarrassed cuz our house is
small like I I and they might have all
got together and been like hey let's
just we're we're trying we're trying to
help y'all out we don't embarrass y'all
because they clearly see what I'm saying
yeah totally I think there's something
about a going Reckless
Allin and Reckless all in I don't who
cares how big your house is and then
I've got yeah that's kind of where we're
at now we're just we don't know how to
take it to that next step after that
like if we go all Reckless like what
does that look like it feels like dating
without a guide book only if you're
doing this for Roi
purposes I hang out with my friends cuz
I like my
friends like I don't I don't have a
reference point for like how many times
and are they doing this without us and
what about this I expect my friends to
have other
friends and I'm not dating them so like
if I when I was exclusive with my wife
if she was going out with other boys I
would be like hey what's the deal but
she didn't do that I don't have that
same expectation for my adult friends I
just firmly expect my adult friends
especially my new ones to have friends
with other adults oh totally yeah and I
think we acknowledge that and I think
yeah I think we just want to know just
how to build meaningful relationship not
not for an Roi invite people
over yeah and just keep getting over
just continue to lean into that yeah I I
mean nothing you've told me sounds weird
it sounds like a group of people of mean
said hey we want to do birthday party X
we don't want them to feel weird cuz
they clearly don't want us around they
don't even have us to their house they
don't come to things whenever we're
going on double dates whatever let's
just do this together and it sounds like
they might have been trying to do it to
help yall out because they don't want to
make y'all feel awkward yeah sure I
think that's what we started telling
ourselves the positive narrative how you
spun it and then in inviting them in
it's gotten a lot like we feel like the
relationships are even better and like
we're closer with people and enjoy like
they enjoyed being at our house you know
we enjoy being around them and we've
even done more stuff on the weekend
since leaning in I think that initial
hurt and just not being honest with us
you know it just hurt it you know it
hurts finding stuff out like that yeah I
mean I get I mean I get I get I guess I
I get that um I think you'll have some
pretty firm expectations some high
expectations especially being a new
group to a new town with some
potentially established
friendships
um and also holding it with an open hand
we we all we all came together at the
same time so and we've been we've been
hanging out for about three years right
at the start of Co okay yeah I I mean I
I just dude I wouldn't overthink it and
I've I've got some new friends that I
made here in my town in my rural
community they're amazing David Ricky
some of these guys are incredible
they're awesome and they get together
once a month or something to play uh
like is it Dungeons and dragon some cart
some game right
they've never one time asked hey would
you like to come over and play this game
with
us I think they just kind of know it's
not really my jam they get together dude
they get snacks they stay up all night
it's this whole thing they're inviting
their boys in not one time have I ever
been
invited and would I like to be invited
that'd be awesome would I ever go never
right and they know that and so like I'm
so excited that my friends have this
weird thing they do
and I've never invited them to heavy
metal band
practice I don't even know if they can
play
instruments see what I'm saying like I I
I would take the hurt and the D the the
the the dating language kind of out of
it I mean it's cool to be like man honey
I wish they we got invited to the
birthday party yeah we need to make sure
we invite everybody when we do it I'm
kind of moving on my day I'm not going
to give them that you know what I mean
oh totally that makes total sense yeah
and then like you mentioned when you
start opening up that's why people
always ask me how do I make friends I
always say you go first and you be
weird because waiting for somebody else
to go first or waiting for somebody else
to invite you waiting for somebody else
to be vulnerable first then it's just
this weird you know Dosey Do here we go
like uh prominade your partner on the
old oak tree kind of like everyone's
just dancing around the reality and so
it's something else when you invite
somebody over like this is my house
that's how we
roll and yeah that makes total sense I
think yeah I think that we've realized
that we were closed off and potentially
it was on our shoulders for not uh being
open first and so yeah leaning in that's
I I would just keep being weird dude I'd
keep being weird I'd keep being weird
and if a group of friends decides
quietly they don't want you around you
can do one of two things you can say hey
man I know this y like a lot of stuff
been going on you don't invite me have I
made this weird or am I awkward or
something and they might say yeah dude
like like here's the X and the Y and the
Z or they might say no dude we just want
to be like we we know every time we go
out you guys don't either don't eat or
we don't want to make it
weird um or our kids have more in common
with ex or with why I see that happen a
lot too that the kids say hey our kid
doesn't want to hang out with these kid
and and so the parents kind of drift
that way too it could be any number of
things at the end of the day of course
grieve it man we thought these were our
friends and they're not or we thought
these are our friends and they lied to
us that
sucks and then we're going to be about
grieving it and then moving on to what's
next but it sounds like you guys have a
pattern of having expectations about a
relationship that the other party
doesn't have and then getting as you say
hurt when those expectations aren't met
across the board and so I'd either be
super clear about my expectations or
dude just kind of loosen your grip on it
a little bit y'all aren't dating these
are just grownup friends navigating a
whole like work and family and and kids
all of it all sports all of it all
together hold it with some empty hands
my guess is you're going to start
spending more and more time with people
um fewer and fewer people and those
relationships are going to get Tighter
and Tighter and Tighter be awesome hang
in there
brother